alors sans que vous vous battez contre
le pass sanitaire que vous juger
inefficace et vous vous gardez votre
restaurant ouvert mais pas de passé à
l'inter saison je ne demande pas à mes
clients de me présenter le pasa knitter
s'ils veulent le présenter le présent
mais c'est pas une obligation pour venir
manger chez moi ou boire un verre chez
moi vous avez déjà été contrôlés non non
d'après l'émission
ce soir
c'est le risque mais quand on défend une
idée je pense qu'il faut aller jusqu'au
bout il ya eu des manifestations il ya
des gens sur certains plateaux qui se
disent où qu'ils se cachent moi je pense
que il est bien de témoigner à visage
découvert et que les gens puissent voir
qu'à des restaurateurs qui assume le
fait de ne pas compliquer fortement
demandés pas de femme est inquiète vous
savez quoi les répercussions à la part
de jean-michel percussions ça va
maintenant les répercussions que
pourrait avoir alors mais on m'a dit
vous avez choisi de venir parce que vous
voulez défendre votre cause et qu'est ce
qui pourrait vous contrôlez pas pourquoi
en fait vous mettez en oeuvre la loi
voilà oui bien sûr mais parce que ce
pass anita on le sait à la base ce n'est
pas un passe sanitaire s'est juste fait
pour pousser les gens à la vaccination
didier ledoux j lors de l'allocution de
maquereaux on sait très bien que les
gens se sont bac signer pour partir en
vacances pour aller au resto j'entends
dire sur ce plateau ou ailleurs que
c'est une cause citoyenne ainsi de suite
non les gens se sont fait vacciner en
majorité pour pouvoir être tranquille
pendant les vacances donc à partir de là
je ne vois pas pourquoi on nous la dre
anne où les restaurateurs s'étaient fans
et là on nous a imposé bien des choses
depuis le début de cette crise crise qu
vide ça je pense que c'est la mesure de
trop sans joie avec les resto routier
qui eux ne sont pas obligés de demander
le pass annie tard pourquoi eux et pas
nous alors vous c'est quoi des sanctions
aujourd'hui mais il y en a eu 1 dans le
var là il ya la semaine dernière je
crois il a eu 1500 euros d'amendé sept
jours de fermeture administrative
d'accord voilà stéphane manigold vous
vous n'êtes pas du tout d'accord vous
êtes restaurateur également n'être pas
du tout d'accord avec ce que avec franck
et je suis pas d'accord parce que je
suis un républicain et un démocrate
c'est à dire que j'accepte le débat on a
ferraillé dur contre le gouvernement sur
le sujet du passé ni terre on a obtenu
un sursis lors de l'ouverture du mois de
mai on n'a pas eu de passé ni terre
lorsque les terrasses ont ouvert
contrairement à ce qui avait été annoncé
et puis variant delta plus qui a
perturbé les chiffres et c'était ça ou
la fermeture est donc moins entre passer
un tout petit peu de temps à contrôler
l'ipo tenant jusqu'à quand un petit peu
de temps je suis annoncé ce soir
que se reposer c'est une chose mais
j'aimerais juste quand même dire une
chose moi je vais voyager cet été en
france disons le en alsace et l'ensemble
de la profession
préfère rester ouverts que de fermer et
donc se passa ni terre qui au fond on
l'a on l'a vidé de substance soyons
clair c'était un an d'emprisonnement
45000 euros damende non
seulement reculé mais selon d'amendé le
rapprochement dimensionné
mon nom c'est d'aller en italie la une
où le maire à emmanuel macron quand ils
reculent il avait déjà prévu de reculer
ça s'appelle la politique ils ont croire
qu'ils ont élargi le passage avec leurs
ados s'y met c'est totalement faux il
avait déjà prévu ça parce qu'ils
savaient que c'était intenable c'est
tout jean messia
moi je suis un peu partagé c'est vrai
que l'idée d'un pass and it et moi ça me
prenait ça me passe à des années
lumières au dessus de la loi par le
débat sur le jeu comprend bon évidemment
moi je suis aussi un républicain je
comprends qu'il ya une loi et qu'on peut
et que tout le monde peut pas
s'accommoder de loi comme il veut mais
par contre sur le principe je suis
d'accord avec avec son initiative un
restaurateur il n'a pas à contrôler ce
qui est des skis les deux ce qui est
devenu une sorte d'app vaille sanitaire
boire un verre dans un pays
libre
ces jours mais c'est celle de l'état
c'est un bâtiment non et c'est un dos et
un docu laissé l'impression de vous
répondre de seconde j'ai pas fini mon
trop où il en est on s'arrête deux
minutes
ça les rend si l'allemagne nazie ardiden
importe quoi mais c'est juste que ébats
si je ne comprends pas qu'on puisse
aujourd'hui dans un pays démocratique
mais dans un pays de lure alicia
2000 et moi je vais vous dire je
commence à en avoir marre de ces mecs
qui font des références à la son odeur
de l'histoire devait faire du buzz avec
vous fait pas du buzz là dessus at war
était avec sa ge est devenue maintenant
là c'est vrai maintenant c'est devenu la
mode non mais c'est avec son bonus
à déranger moi les gens quand je sais
que quand je suis que choix de traiter
de personnes d'extrême droite depuis
cinq ans alors si c'est pas
parce que vous n'étiez a été débouté
mais moi je digresse à chaud me dit que
je suis très droit et salarié perçoit
arrêter de penser à vous là vous pensez
à des millions de gens qu'ils ont
arrêtés
moi je voudrais répondre à franck quand
ya eu des aides gouvernementales et
étatiques vous avez pris les aides non
j'ai galéré je les ai pas touché c'est
très bien que vous lanciez sur ce sujet
j'avais refusé les aides et l'enjeu
n'est pas de refuser je ne les ai pas
touché je suis le mois de février alors
est-ce que c'est pas pour ça est ce que
vous n'avez pas dormir et kouadio l'état
mais pour que nous arrange moi je vais
vous dire a dû en criant votre rémy
grand v pense à ma place un message
toujours pas la vérité doit penser en
tant que client de votre récente j'ai
dit non si j'en étais je ne mettrai pas
que vous ne me contrôle y ait pas c'est
que vous le concert pour les clients qui
veulent venir regarder au delà des faux
pas sanitaire qui existent leur accord
il ya là des fonds olympien n'a pas
plein
la place et laissez-moi vous répandant
qu'il ya plein de faux pas déjà ah oui
ensuite il ya les personnes des
colloques des gens qui veulent venir
boire un verre yalin le soir et dit non
non moi j'ai un exam de là je suis
vacciné je sors pas tiens prends mon
pass le gars à locaux vides ils
contaminent quelqu'un d'autre à qui la
faute
non mais je ne contrôle pas parce que ce
n'est pas son passé ni terra lui et ça
peut arriver sur plein d'autres je parle
même pas des étrangers qui peuvent venir
ou là on peut pas lire les
ridicules c'est inapplicable mieux on
peut pas les laisser tranquilles les
restaurateurs c'est eux qui ont le plus
souffert de la crise économique est là
enroulé vient tuer leurs courbes leur
profession je vous donner un chiffre il
enregistre une baisse de 40 pour nom de
leur fréquentation depuis la mise en
place du pass sanitaire c'est dramatique
et en plus ils sont obligés d'affecter
un salarié au contrôle des passes annie
terre donc ça représente encore un coup
en plus donc franchement je trouve ça
tout à fait normal que ce monsieur ne
contrôle pas les passes sanitaires et je
suis sûr qu'il ya plein de clients qui
sont très contents de venir désolé
monsieur sophie moi je comprends
parfaitement votre logique est votre
positionnement extra par rapport au
passé et le fait que vous soyez contre
le passé mais vous tire un peu une balle
dans le pied c'est ça le problème moi ça
me fait de la peine pour vous parce que
je me dis en plus vous venez ici ce soir
témoigner donc on forcément on va
s'intéresser à votre restaurant je me
dis vous avez eu des mesures qui ont été
mises en place qui était beaucoup plus
difficile à appliquer par rapport à
l'association l'épreuve 6 tu as là c'est
quand même assez rapide de ce qu'est mon
truc qu'on s'en fout admettons non non
on ne met pas non mais parce que je
comprends que je n'ai pas dit je ne
supporte toujours au long des
restaurateurs
sera tout sauf un ils tuent me
représente pas non plus donc ça déclare
non plus que ce soit votre droit et
votre liberté de ne pas le faire mais je
trouve que pour vous c'est dommageable
le voyez ce que je veux mais j'en suis
conscient et finalement j'en suis
conscient
de toute façon le passé ni terre on est
dedans jusqu'au cou jusqu'à je sais pas
combien de temps on l'a pourquoi est-ce
que vous ruiner finalement votre affaire
pour un truc qui prend 3
j'espère qu'ils ont à faire c'est
laisser leur accord le feront également
qu'ils le feront et je le laissais
lorsqu'il aura abandonné waters france
au danemark le pas sera abandonnée comme
en russie et en fin de semaine que ce
sera le cas et si je dois avoir quelques
préjudice que ce soit pour avoir fait
avancer cette cause
celui qui se tire une balle dans le pied
c'est pas avoir le courage de dire ce
qu'on pensait venir de venir sur le
plateau on prend des risques c'est pas
avoir le courage quant au fils gilles tu
es vraiment complète et candide
franchement croix qui a pas de faux
j'étais avec cinq copains en vacances
sur les cinq navettes 3 km et fo ils
sont fait gauler seulement qu'on a été
on voulait jouer un peu à la machination
ou casino il avait demandé face et
cartes d'identité cela qui oblige les
égos les il n'avait pas les bompassencs
et en peluche où il ya des tensions géré
comme un restaurateur à biarritz où il
ya des clients qui ont failli taper
taper le restaurateur mon copain franck
parce que on lui refuser de s'asseoir
avec sa femme et ses enfants parce qu'il
n'avait pas le pass voilà il a les
faillites a failli en venir aux mains
mais je suis pas payé pour ça je fais
pas ce métier là pour me faire taper
dessus puisque j'ai pas le cas
mais juste on est tous d'accord sur le
plat c'est compliqué mais pendant huit
mois 12 mois ils ont été fermés voilà
une façon de laisser ouvert qui t'ont
fait on va recommencer on va faire tous
les restaurants je comprends très noir
la solution web
le pass il fallait pas possible ça
pourra mais on a beau dire on est pas
possible qu en france mais ça york en
clarifiant ses fans te concernant je
suis désolé moitié il faut être honnête
intellectuellement moi je connais pas
beaucoup de restaurateurs qui mène dans
une émission de télé avec un directeur
de cabinet politique ils ont clarifié le
sujet franck meyer c'est un combat
politique que tu m'aimes tu es tout
militant politique j'étais dans le
xivème pardon il est de quel droit de
droite droite faut être clair j'étais
aux alertes ou alors si mais j'ai tissé
l'a précédé moi parce que tu sais moi je
commence à être agacé à chaque forme et
des des pseudos restaurateurs en face de
moi qui parle en eau des restaurateurs
put mans ça c'est toi qui te fait un kit
permettant leur faute et un terme à ses
salariés deux toi ta femme moi et pour
40 couverts je suis pas d'eux donc
deuxièmement j'ai vérifié on sait que ça
arrive et ça pardon et je respect n'est
pas seule mais tu es un épicier donc
d'un compas un restaurateur c'est pas
parce que tu fais des planches jacques
dutronc sera entendue chez emi points 7
je suis fait de la vente je veux tu dis
là de quoi emporter n'est pas sous mieux
c'est de le dire alors je voudrais pas
que tu as des couilles en plein dans
milk
[Applaudissements]
sa hausse et pour longtemps acquis
[Rires]
des mêmes débats bêta paga qu'il est a
des couilles en posture ouest washington
pour forcer pour y faire des communes
pourrait donc aussi répondre à ce que tu
appelles tu peux laisser fonctionner si
tu veux comme dans les séries dans les
frères de sang les restaurateurs
d'accord je suis pas une évolution
d'accord
et c'est parler franchement de balle je
suis restaurateur premièrement on est
déclaré comme tel mais peu importe c'est
comme ça c'est vrai mais peu importe
c'est comme ça effectivement fait
d'aller les prix par rapport à tous les
petits restaurateurs pour toi qui sont
en face tu aimais prix or est une
victime s'était pas politique et ainsi
de suite j'ai fait des réunions avec toi
dans les restaurants tu te glorifier
d'avoir accès au bureau de bruno le
maire donc oui j'étais à droite il ya
peut-être un combat politique de
l'agencé
pti lisez les connue est la langue
des restaurateurs de emmanuel lacroix de
bruno le maire sur les plateaux tv mais
si elles sont
toutes à l'extrême droite dit le
père je termine dernier pour la cgt même
temps il avait monté et avaient monté un
mouvement qui s'appelait restons ouverts
on est ouvert à quel moment tout reste
ouvert tu as toujours fermée tu t'es ap
l'amertume des coûts fait c'est tout
voilà et toi tu as fais pas
[Applaudissements]
woerth est resté ferme et à toucher les
aides comme il le dit gilles verdez et
on jugera tort parce que ton sujet on en
a discuté hors sujet il n'a pas le droit
aux aides pourquoi parce que il fait de
la vente en porte
elle-même
pour vous mais la vraie question à la
question où est la vraie question
conférer une minute pour vous qui a des
couilles en plastique
je peux tu as des couilles en plastique
lui devant macro il y en a plus du tout
d'accord très bien merci